reject nation what is going on we are
going to watch today from new rock stars
vetom post credit scene the talk of the
town right now explained as much as we
had a kick out of this post credit scene
and what it ultimately sets up oh yeah
there's a lot to be excited about i do
have some worries about it that uh i
will have to be more specific about
maybe i'll mention some of it here in
this video maybe not but either way
we're gonna be doing a live stream
spoiler talk this coming monday so
please make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified once
we're live either like 10 or 11 in the
morning one of those time frames is what
we're looking at right now let's see
what's going on because as cool as it
was as clear as what's setting up
there's some stuff to be explained about
what's really going on and who better
than the voss boss
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and venom let there be carnage ends
with a post credit scene that'll make
you say oh [ __ ]
spoiler warning go watch venom let there
be carnage with the rest of the
shrieking shrieks because i'm gonna
break down the final minutes of this
film for the way it bends reality ahead
of spider-man no way home and other
future marvel crossovers let's hear it
okay as this movie comes to a close and
venom gobbles up his daily dosages of
carnage and clevis cassidy he and eddie
brock end up fleeing to a tropical beach
and on this beautiful friendship is
where the post-credits scene picks up
eddie rests in his hotel watching
telenovelas with venom and debating
whether it is okay to keep secrets in
relationships and venom says we all have
a past eddie and goes on to tease 80
billion light years of hive knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain and then he offers eddie
let me give you a taste of just the
smallest fractions of the things we
symbiotes have experienced a plus
commitment i think we are about to
explore the deeper mythology of venom
symbiote klyntar race perhaps even their
original deity null who first
established the klyntar as a hive mind
with himself as the nexus of it as he
bore all black the necker sword assorted
very important mcu ties as the weapon of
gore the god butcher yeah that's where
all of our minds went pretty much every
audience member
every eyesore was like oh we're about to
go into the klintar race definitely god
they're deity though yeah we got so much
to go into
finally i've been waiting for all this
stuff to show up in the mcu it's about
time that's where my mind jumped to us
where everyone's match up to even the
casual viewers jumped in there
that's what most casual viewers think of
when they think of venus but before our
cooler older brothers punch us in the
shoulder and call us nerds things take a
turn because the hotel room quakes the
tv flickers the wallpaper and furniture
warp around eddie into a much fancier
room as golden light floods from the
outside the ceiling fan goes from
spinning rapidly as it does in the not
as good hotel rooms too much higher and
just been more casual you know rich
people stealing fans even eddie's
backpack warps from his rugged hiking
pack to a smaller teal carry-on though
we learn it is not his after calming
venom down about the swan folded towels
and he asks what he just did and venom
claims it wasn't me
and then boom on the tv
reporting that peter parker is
spider-man the same moment from the
spider-man far from home post-credits
scene and in the upcoming spider-man no
way home yes this is tom holland
spider-man from the mcu it's happening
folks venom just jumped realities into a
cinematic universe that we actually care
about jamison
this shocking revelation brought to life
by yours truly peter parker aka
spider-man aka spider menace rest
assured dear neighbors we hear the daily
bugle will untangle his web of lies i'm
james jonah jameson good night and god
help us all and then eddie turns into
venom
voice acting that guy and creepily licks
peter's face on the screen then another
dude comes to the bathroom asking eddie
what he's doing in his room and eddie is
speechless as am i
talking about this for weeks and i will
you will i think we are now witnessing
the effects of doctor strange's spell in
spider-man no way okay and peter parker
tampering with that spell and or any of
the other preceding multiverse rupturing
events from the mcu all culminating in
the crossover crisis of spider-man no
way home okay so this would
lend some i don't think so yet but it
could lend some type of credence towards
the argument that maybe the sixth member
of the sinister six like i said i don't
believe but some people do that venom
might be the sixth member of the
sinister secret i don't think it's gonna
happen but a lot of people are
championing for that based off of the
way venom reacts
it would seem that maybe in this 80
billion whatever maybe he does have some
history with some version of spider-man
that we didn't see because it was
the universe is part of the hive
consciousness the best way to find out
about a long-standing rivalry or maybe
their first act as lethal protector is
that that we are here let's go and kill
this
that means tom hardy's venom is
officially mcu cannon and not this weird
vaguely defined side universe in the
sony spumsy this is the latest of sony's
machinations to fold all of their
spider-verse film properties into an
epic crossover event with the marvel
cinematic universe in november
shows us what that crossover looks like
from the perspective of one of those
traveling characters mid-warp there's a
golden flash of light perhaps caused by
one of the golden runic bands of doctor
strange's spell and then one's
surroundings texturally roll over around
them similar to how wanda maximoff's hex
reality house chaotically switched to
new furniture in wanavision therefore
when auto octavius norman osborne or max
dillon get transferred from their
realities they'll probably go through a
similar warp into parallel mcu variant
contexts like alfred molina hinted that
his character would pick up from that
moment in the river and now we are
likely to see him warp from drowning in
the hudson to safely on the deck of the
staten island ferry and then when doc
comes back he's gonna be like i changed
my mind
as peter was sinking to the depths all i
could think of was i should have killed
that
i don't know why i changed my mind no
i'm sure there's gonna be a much bigger
explanation we're just cracking jokes
norman osborne could go from facing the
jaws of his own glider oh
two facing the jaws of mr delmore's cat
oh good
now in eddie brock's universe the daily
bugle is a print newspaper with the same
masthead as the one in the sam raimi
films but in the mcu the daily bugle is
an infowars style online broadcast with
a different logo eddie went from a vice
style tv investigator in the 2018 film
to a print reporter now and cletus
cassidy even mocked his sagging
readership so part of eddie and venom
now might salivate at a version of the
daily bugle that could get scoops this
massive here we see tom holland peter
parker standing awkwardly unmasked
outside of penn station suggesting this
is moments after his outing in the far
from home post credit scene maybe after
those onlookers mobbed him and took off
his mask as we saw in the no way home
trailer i'm guessing that shot is not
even in spider-man no way home they just
did that weird looking posing shot this
perfectly a screener costume test they
had lying around or some b-roll of tom
i'm just saying like the way that shot
is it's a bit odd maybe it is something
where they composited it out of some
other thing but it's just so crystal cut
clear it looks like promo footage you
know there you go it's an odd
replacement of that it doesn't look real
so does this main venom will appear in
spider-man no way home maybe even as
that sixth villain we've all been
speculating about well this plus tom
hardy's no way home hat seems to confirm
yeah now it is possible that venom is
just in the mcu now and won't actually
participate in no way home and instead
won't meet spider-man until venom three
or something but really thematically all
this talk and let there be carnage about
them being a lethal protector was a
direct nod to the venom lethal protector
comics in which spider-man and venom
team up venom could be one of the
multiversal arrivals who helps peter
parker deal with all those other threats
and no way home dude
that's exactly what everyone yeah let's
skip the rivalry and go right
up that's what everyone wants no uncle
ben skip it we don't need it no rivalry
between eddie and peter skip it we don't
need it see that's where i'm having a
hard time wrapping my head around is
like why would venom not like peter
partner is there gonna be a symbiote
story told with peter where he where
venom attaches himself to peter why
would this like
45 year old reporter who's transported
to this universe hate this high schooler
kid so much so i don't know what
machinations they would conjure up to
make sure they can still have a rivalry
because what i imagine what they would
probably be doing because venom is
clearly painted in the heroic light with
this franchise is that best case it
would seem is that venom and
peter parker would be enemies at first
and eventually they would team up that
just seems like the path that's headed
where you know venom would continue to
be a hero or they might just skip that
all together and make them here yeah
i mean i could absolutely see any array
of things happening you never know i
don't know i think it would be very very
odd to do that unless they justify it by
going venom just recognizes the suit or
something which i could see but i just
wouldn't be satisfied it's going to be
satisfying or personal because it feels
like all these villains that he's
fighting are from other universes that
have never had a person
all have really personal times to a
peter but not our peter or the fcu yeah
i don't know i feel like if venom shows
up at all in no way home i would hope
that it's in a small supporting capacity
much like a lot of the other characters
because yeah it's not about building his
relationship up with venom and eddie
brock in that movie you know even though
venom says it wasn't him who triggered
this reality warp we gotta admit it's
pretty coincidental that it happens
right as he asked eddie if he was ready
for that's the movie
80 billion light years perhaps it was
trying to expand eddie's mind that might
have been why strange's spell selected
them from this moment because the spell
does have a certain wish fulfillment
aspect to it and perhaps the spell's
malfunctioned whipped together other
entities who overreached their mind's
ability to grasp their linkage to a high
network of variants i think you're
giving this movie too much crap
yeah if you've seen you've seen the
movie right
[Laughter]
i wish i wish it was now there has been
some talk of the live-action
spider-verse being a manifestation of
what comics nerds call the web of life
and destiny which could be overseen by
the comics figure
now i don't know if the movies will go
that far but i do think spider-man no
way home may try to give an in-universe
answer to why there have been separate
universes like why venom can exist in
the universe without spider-man when in
the comics his whole thwippiness is only
because he was attached to spider-man
before he latched onto that rock and
this in-universe y doesn't have to be
because sony just kept rebooting him
yeah we get it but maybe from a
narrative standpoint because the mcu
multiverse was destined to rupture in
doctor strange foresaw a need for
multiple heroes with separate life
experiences to combine their knowledge
to keep the multiverse from spiraling
into madness and brace yourself folks
because it is not going to stop with
spider-man characters in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness coming
march 2022 it has been confirmed that
the scarlet witch will face one major
fox marvel character meaning one of the
x-men or the fantastic four and in this
movie we heard francis barrison call her
powers mutation which used to be a
marvel no-no word but now that this is
all linked to one big mcu with mutants
on the horizon the multiverse of madness
is here i'm glad you pointed that out
because that is something that flew over
a lot of people's heads you know it's
just because they don't say mutant yeah
because mutation is just a that's just
science words
it's just a real word and say mutant
mutants is a made-up concept only for
the x-men eddie brock in an alternate
reality hotel room will just be the
first of many familiar faces who are
going to wake up to find themselves in a
room with captain america wallpaper i
mean it can't just be me who wakes up to
that hey you can support new rockstars
by checking out our merch options
rockstars.creature follow me on
instagram and twitter
are you gonna call dibs is that it
with your like 10 million billion
spiderman and venom t-shirts
are you buying it right now on camera is
that what you're doing so that i can
never claim
the venom shirt thank you eric voss for
putting this figure together i have some
online purchases to make right now
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already keep a lookout
for our live stream this does explain a
lot that i my mind did not go to i'll
link it to the klintars guys
if you look out and hey let's do a pic
fluff doritos if there's anyone right
now who would love to
experience some type of spider-man no
way home multiverse transportation
thingamajig it would be you because from
my understanding the marvel enthuses you
you are not able to see this right now
based off where you're located in the
world that you're gonna have to wait a
while that sucks and i am so sorry if i
was able to have you latch on to me we
can symbiote so ourselves together i
would totally take you to the theaters
grab you a large popcorn maybe eat the
guy's head in front of us but
unfortunately that's not real life
real life is the u.s gets first dibs on
the big movies except for bond
anyway phleb sorry man's a weird shout
out hopefully you're doing well brother